[Musique]
nagasaki est certainement l'une des
villes les plus émouvantes du japon
émouvante d'abord parce que son charme
est très grand et ensuite parce que ce
charme est un charme triste nagasaki en
effet une ville qui meurt doucement au
siècle dernier à nagasaki avait dû sa
fortune au fait que son corps avait été
le premier du japon à s'ouvrir au grand
commerce international ou en commerce
avec l'occident grâce aux hollandais
grâce aux portugais et au fait qu'il
constituait la porte naturelle du japon
vers la chine vers shanghai et surtout
vers ses colonies de formose et de corée
or d'une part les échanges commerciaux
entre le japon et la chine sont
aujourd'hui réduits pratiquement à néant
et d'autre part le japon
comme vous le savez a perdu ses colonies
de formose et deux corées alors nagasaki
ayant perdu du même coup l'essentiel de
ces raisons de vivre nagasaki c'est un
meurt doucement avec un stoïcisme très
japonais et cette tristesse nagasaki ce
charme triste dont je vous ai parlé on
l'éprouvent extrêmement vite lorsque
l'on découvre la ville lorsque l'on
flâne à travers ses vieux quartiers
[Musique]
non
et nagasaki est une ville construite à
flanc de colline et beaucoup de
ruisseaux décembre des auteurs de ces
collines et baignent les vieux quartiers
les vieux quartiers humide et gris de
nagasaki et ses ruisseaux servent aussi
bien de l'avoir municipal que de bains
douches quelquefois mêmes il faut bien
le dire assez souvent aussi de tout à
l'égout
mon
oh
[Musique]
ceci n'est pas une manifestation
d'étudiants
c'est un simple orchestre ambulant qui
parcouraient les rues de nagasaki
espérant qu'elles courent
je vous ai dit que nagasaki été
construites à flanc de colline c'est une
vie dans vérité où l'on a l'impression
de toujours monter et de ne jamais
descendre
et comme toutes les villes du japon
le nombre des enfants en liberté non est
un à gaza quelque chose de stupéfiant
[Musique]
brigitte bardot possède déjà une
réputation flatteuse et même des
admirateur fervent des rêves
[Musique]
oh
mais je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
nagasaki est une ville triste ville qui
s'éteignait
ceci est vrai si l'on fait exception
toutefois une activité extrêmement
importante que l'on rencontre à nagasaki
et qui est la construction navale comac
commune
nous sommes ici au chantier mitsubichi
qui s'étendent sur des kilomètres et des
kilomètres dans la benne à gaza qu avec
280 mille tonnes construite en 1957
ces chantiers mitsubishi qui sont
presque centenaire ont non seulement
battue est très largement tous leurs
records d'avant guerre
mais ils se sont également imposés comme
les chantiers navals numéro un du monde
la construction navale japonaise dans sa
totalité
occupant je vous le rappelle le deuxième
rang mondial derrière celle des états
unis
mais les états unis n'ayant par contre
aucun chantier aussi vaste et aussi
productifs que celui de mitsubishi à
nagasaki
il
on
[Musique]
je crois qu'il est utile d'ailleurs
d'ajouter que ce chantier naval que vous
avez sous les yeux fait partie d'un
gigantesque trust qui groupe également
sous l'égide de mitsubishi des usines
métallurgiques des raffineries de
pétrole des compagnies de navigation une
chaîne de grands magasins etc
ces trusts familiaux qu'on appelait
avant la guerre les high bats où il y en
avait deux autres très important celui
de mythes sont et celui de souvenirs et
mots qu'il dominait toute l'économie
japonaise c'est à iba dessous donc
furent dissous par macarthur
après la capitulation du japon et leurs
diverses entreprises sur dix ne vaut
mais immédiatement après le traité de
paix entre les etats-unis et le japon
les ipad sous se sont reconstitués ils
ont retrouvé peu à peu leur force et
leur prospérité d'avant guerre et ils
ont repris leur place à la tête de
l'économie japonaise dont l'expérience
de démocratisation tant départ macarthur
s'est finalement soldée par un échec
la démocratisation politique du japon se
révélera tel plus efficace il faudra je
crois attendre de longues années pour
pouvoir se prononcer sur ce
[Musique]
le
et puis en dehors des chantiers navals
la pêche est également l'une des rares
activités qui demeure à nagasaki la gaza
qui reste en effet le port de pêche le
plus important de l'île de kyushu et
même de tout le sud du japon est le
véritable ravitailleur de celui-ci ans
trois sont de toutes tailles je précise
car évidemment cela sont assez modestes
mais attendez un peu
je
[Musique]
voici des requins tout de même assez
impressionnant
[Musique]
et ici des requins marteaux
mais voyez vous j'en reviens à ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure
l'impression qui domine à nagasaki est
celle d'une ville morte d'un port vide
dans notre prochaine émission qui sera
en même temps la dernière de notre série
nous vous emmènerons à hiroshima
[Musique]